The number of dimes to the number of quarters is 2 to 3. So, if I reverse that
ratio, the number of quarters to the number of dimes must be 3 to 2. I can write
that with words, with a colon, or as a fraction. The second one was really
tricky. I don't know the total number of dimes and I don't know the total number
of coins So, what can I do? Well, let's try some cases. If I started out with
two dimes, I'd have to have 3 quarters, which would be 5 coins in total. But I
didn't necessarily have to start with 2 dimes. What if I started with 4 dimes? I
doubled the number of dimes that I started with. So, I also need to double my
number of quarters. So, 4 dimes would have 6 quarters, which would be 10 coins
in total. Notice that 2 divides into 4 and 10. 2 is the common factor, so I can
simplify this fraction. And even if I had 6 dimes, I would have to have 9
quarters, or 15 coins in total. And this fraction still reduces to 2 5ths. I
removed a 3 as the common factor. That's pretty incredible. I didn't even know
the total number of coins, or the total number of dimes, but I knew the ratio.
It was 2 to 5. If you didn't get the second part of the problem right, that's
okay. I just wanted to get you thinking about ratios.